I read that you'll never find another
like me the album came out last week and
it's just it's so exciting for me
because I got to write every song on
that album and it like is good I'm
seventeen of course I miss my friends
but I don't have like a husband and kids
at home this is my first Grammys I've
ever been to and I'm already so
overwhelmed there are so many famous
people here how do you handle it how do
you just contain yourself
[Music]
when we first met Taylor Swift in 2006
she was just at the beginning of her
giant rise to startup plan to 20,000
feet one night kind of awesome sometimes
you take like 4 hours to write a song
but this song I wrote in 15 minutes
[Music]
we kept meeting on red carpets at
different award shows and we noticed one
thing right away the Pennsylvania native
who started writing her own songs at the
age of 12 and became the world's
top-earning celeb of 2019 is super savvy
was that on audio interference you want
me to repeat because I was rambling too
and I'd rather get a clean one
I looked in the camera sorry I always do
that yep Tay knew exactly where to look
what to say and most important she
always knew her passion was music I feel
like I didn't miss out on a childhood I
got to go to school I got to go to my
first two years of high school and
experience all that
[Music]
and then I got to go on the road and
play shows every night and do what I've
always dreamed of doing and I just
graduated high school I just got my
diploma in the mail which was really fun
make no mistake
Taylor success didn't happen by accident
lover sold more than three million
copies in its first week I have a really
great team of people who don't mind that
I'm really a control freak
I love a challenge and I think that
right now the challenge is figuring out
the next challenge and there's always
something
[Music]
it's interesting because being 22 that's
the age when most people are like you're
22 what are you supposed to make
mistakes and live your life and learn
lessons and then you then you go like oh
no if I make mistakes and learn lessons
that's like a headline if you got a live
a life you're gonna be proud of
[Music]
tailors kind of the queen of hidden
messages putting little easter eggs in
her music videos and on Instagram six
months before dropping her seventh album
she posted a picture sitting on the
seventh step from the top and seven palm
trees but are we really surprised
Taylor's been working her social media
skills since way back when all there was
was my space for my myspace I treat it
like it's my personal myspace I don't
treat it like it's a like promotional
tool to promote my music you know it's
like I really like to put stuff about
Who I am as a person because that's what
myspace I thought was supposed to be for
[Music]
of course this year Taylor and Katy
Perry ended their five years of bad
blood she was like I would love for us
to be a symbol of redemption and
forgiveness and I feel great about it
yes Taylor's always been about female
empowerment and her girl squad the
original member one of my best friends
is Emma Stone so if I could ever act in
anything with Emma that would be a dream
come true I try to keep my close friends
in my life all the time just I think it
keeps you who you are and having Selena
there and just kind of turning into a
dance party that's always really fun
when award shows turn into more of like
a girls night situation cos darling I'm
a nightmare dressed like a daydream but
what we appreciate the most is the way
Taylor totally gets us when it comes to
relationships the way she writes about
her own love life makes many of us feel
less alone you might think I'd bring up
Joe that guy who broke up with me on the
phone I'm not gonna mention him in my
monologue and if you're wondering if I
might be dating the werewolf from
Twilight from SNL to basically every
song on her albums behold the list of
her inspirations Joe Jonas was the first
in 2008 followed by Taylor Lautner
[Music]
then came John Mayer Jake Gyllenhaal
King Connor Kennedy Harry Styles
[Applause]
Calvin Harris then the other half of
Hittle Swift Tom Hiddleston Betazed
current guy is British actor Joe outlet
now in honor of that long list of
ex-lovers here's everything on the
record about boys and dating the singer
has said since we first met Taylor
eventually in relationship you're gonna
run out of things to talk about so if
you two can laugh about everything like
best friends then you're set I write
songs I write on my own songs and so I'm
inspired most of my boys honestly but I
don't date much so I'm not really
getting heartbroken a lot they never go
into this and be like I really want to
ask you out could you not write songs
about us they say that when we're
breaking out like you better not read
song about this and I'm like oh I won't
and then I do I'm not gonna walk home
with any men tonight I'm gonna go hang
out with my friends and then I go home
to the cats no men allowed then get me
in trouble
[Music]